if you haven't seen Avengers infinity
war yet you might not want to stick
around for the rest of this video
because we're about to talk about the
many casualties of the film and how
Avengers 4 may or may not deal with
those losses consider yourself warned
about spoilers ahead let's go Marvel
fans might still be reeling from all the
ashes to ashes style action in infinity
war but as anyone who's read the
Infinity Gauntlet comic series knows the
time stone couldn't do a lot of that
damage if only someone beside stano's
can get a hold of that glove besides it
sounds like some of the lives lost in
the film still won't be in turn in
Avengers 4 in the emotional aftermath of
infinity war screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely made it clear
that not all the heartbreak and tragedy
fans saw in infinity war will be cleared
away in the follow up and that fans I
shouldn't expect to know what will
happen in the fourth film either Markus
told BuzzFeed Avengers Ford doesn't do
what you think it does it is a different
movie than you think it is also the
deaths are real I just want to tell you
it's real and the sooner you accept that
the sooner you will be able to move on
to the next stage of grief of course
there are some characters who still seem
safe a resurrection considering
spider-man Black Panther and the
guardians of the galaxy of all got
standalone sequels to star in the spike
being reduced to dust in the last few
minutes of Avengers infinity war the
perhaps Marcus is hinting at something
else here maybe the demise is that were
less mystical in infinity war might be
permanent life with Heimdall Loki Gamora
and the vision so even if it seems like
a few fun favorites might make a
comeback audiences should at least be
prepared for some of the infinity walk
advised to be kind of forever meanwhile
McFeely added that even though infinity
war is a fairly mature movie for a
blockbuster fans should also prepare
themselves for even more intensity in
Avengers 4 explaining it's got a lot of
fun in it obviously but boy it gets very
mature the second one is also mature
we're going to own these choices and
hopefully surprise and delight you and
get you invested it's by the same studio
the same filmmaking team they were
written at the same time shut at the
same time he added that while the two
films are clearly connected they are two
independent movies and not just one big
two partner ative as the first film
seemed to set up in other words these
screenwriters are telling us that
Avengers 4 might not pick up exactly
where infinity war left off and proceed
in the direction we think it will to
rescue all our fallen heroes
but with all the time turning action
that may happen in the fourth film even
those characters who might be lost for
good could get a few final cameos to
ease our suffering we'll find out for
sure when Avengers 4 launches in 2019
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love today
[Music]